good morning and thank you very much the
organizers for organizing and altering
this workshop to be to accommodate this
situation so today I'm going to talk to
you about some lessons that have become
a lot more important as we try and build
quantum computers with more qubits so at
one of these lessons I think it'd be
known at various points in the community
and then forgotten because they're not
where the experimental focus has been
but now as we really want to try and
invest multiple billions of dollars
multiple trillions of dollars into
building when computers that a large
scale and can solve interesting problems
you suddenly need to deal with all the
problems of how do you address how do
you characterize quantum systems that
where they're designed to encode to be
more complicated than you can describe
on a digital computer so I'll start with
the very brief overview which I'm sure
you've had a few times before but just
to emphasize the points I've been
getting to be talking about more so why
a quantum computing well this goes back
to the 1980s the idea that if nature is
quantum mechanical and you want to
simulate it then you'd better have a
quantum computer and while the idea was
9 it took a while for the algorithms to
be formalized so this started to happen
in the late 80s with Deutsch and then
concrete algorithms for specific
decision problems like factoring numbers
with sure 94 former formally simulating
quantum systems you 96 searching
databases also 96 solving systems of
linear equations and time-dependent
linear differential equations and
machine learning and you know of course
that there are lot more algorithms but
we're still waiting for the technology
to be ready basically so what is a
quantum computer the ideal computational
model is very simple it consists of
three types of operations we prepare n
systems in initial states require a
sequence of gates and we measure all
systems independently so you can talk
about extra ingredients but these these
ingredients will do - you get a
universal quantum computer if you can
make them over now
this device this computational model
produces samples from the distribution
of utility and outcomes and like all
computers quantum computers share the
most common being they don't work
properly all the time and they're even
less than current computers because
they're more complicated so he's a
picture of my own trap corner computer
or superconducting quantum computer and
these really should be compared so I'd
say the 1940s 1950s era vacuum tube
digital computers it was still got a way
to go so they don't work correctly now
on a digital computer not working
correctly in something like a police of
death or a hard crash what does it mean
well it can also mean a hot hot crasher
for each Milton not going too hot but
when it's working roughly within spec it
means a deviation from correctness where
we have to always treat any kind of
error in a probabilistic sentence but
it's not just did I get the right answer
because I'm always sampling I have to
talk about the probability distributions
and how close is the distribution
actually sample to the one that I want
to sample from and you can quantify
errors in a variety of ways this the
nicest sort of most generic ways to
choose generic distance measures on
probability distributions the
application specific ones which we would
like if you were running applications
but went on which depends on the
application specific topology survey the
show's algorithm that would be how
choice is the number that I get to a
integer factor integer multiple of a
factor so we would like to talk about an
error and errors stochastic processes
and we're talking about errors in a
sampling process so this is something
where you can't cannot ever really say
one particular home run of the
computation had an error
in that it's producing a sample from the
distribution and as long as that's
purple is not impossible is it's
consistent with the distribution but you
would like to be able to evaluate things
on it on a per run level so the nicest
ways to try and come up with the talk
with the notion of an area that that
matches what you want and one nice way
to do that is to talk about a sort of
hidden classical channel kind of like a
Maxwell demon type where you can imagine
that I ain't easy quantum computer is
completely equivalent on a conceptual
level but not on a real level to running
a perfect quantum computer and then
sending the output through a noisy
classical channel that corrupts the data
and then the probability that of a data
corruption is what is the total
variation distance between the two
distributions where I just calculate the
total variation distance by referring to
distributions by taking difference
making absolute value and summing over
all the outcomes okay almost finished
the preliminary stuff so implementing a
quantum computer yeah we have an
abstract model we want to talk about an
implementation of the abstract model and
again we're primarily concerned with
errors in the implementation we're not
ready to run programs that are in
solving here we're not really ready to
try and tackle koban 19 with quantum
computers and so we're not ready to run
programs little in debug so that means
that we need to talk about the errors in
each of the types of instructions
operations and how those there is to
depend on how it's implemented and
luckily the implementation is fairly
consistent across all major platforms
the abstract operation of preparing in
few bits is universally cooing and
systems to the ground state
mathematically if I go to a sufficiently
our children space I've just realized I
was losing color my sight apologies you
know how to hilbert space that's just
preparing some unit vector applying a
sequence of gates corresponds to
applying
time-dependent Hamiltonian those two are
not in one-to-one correspondence and the
mathematical description means that I
apply again unitary evolution in a
larger Hilbert space for continuous time
so it's interest I'm trading for
equation time to penetrate inter
equation an independently measuring
qubits is implemented by measuring the
energy level of each system and that
corresponds to a projector valid measure
in some large Hobart space now if the
focus of this talk is going to be on
applying a sequence of gates and how do
we characterize that neatly and what are
the issues that are raised when we try
and applying gates on multiple qubits so
to break that up we have a time
dependent Hamiltonian that's used to
implement the gates and it's made up
from a system containing H nor instead
of control Hamiltonians and a set of
courses and if you want to know what
what's wrong
you look at the math you take every term
and you say that could be wrong so that
we have different names for the
different ways things in there wrong
rapid fluctuations in the Hamiltonians
either the system or the control we
would talk about as decoherence which
means that we're losing purity on a
state on average we can have imperfect
we know in Hamiltonians actually always
will have imperfectly known Hamiltonians
we have post distortions and these three
different types of errors lead to things
like unitary errors in cross talk the
talk of back to later
with a quantum computers the actual
technology is fundamentally analog which
anytime you're doing with an analog
technology you'll always have
discretization errors always have issues
of you can only learn things for a
finite precision there will always be
errors so why don't we think what I'm
computing is liable well because we can
use quantum error correction to
discretize the errors into nice sets may
we do this to encode information in
whatever set of orthogonal subspaces
process the information measure which
subspace the systems in but by a
correction repeat along a lot of it many
many many many times and decoding
information and each time we do the mesh
term in a class is a system into one of
the orthogonal subspaces with one of the
discrete class of errors but it's a lot
simpler to analyze and predict and also
we can turn continuous parameter things
to much lower dimensional space
important points to note here is that
the correction operator and the
measurement all of these the right
things to do to encode the information
and process it and apply Corrections all
depend upon the precise details of the
error model yeah if you put in a bad
error model and and come up with an
incorrect error model and come up with a
procedure it might not work so the grand
challenge for quantum computing is to
take an abstract circuit and a physical
system and find initialisation
procedures pulses read our procedures
subspaces for encoding correction
operators and everything else so the
encoded computation is sufficiently
accurate and the major constraint you
the whole process must be faster than
simulating the circuit using digital
computers otherwise the compliant
computer is useless you'd basically be
building a a root gold that machine well
I love these they're very fascinating to
watch they're not something that we want
to invest a lot of money building and
they need to global scale
so it's the conventional approach the
conventional approach is to construct
effective operations as preparations
gates and measurements acting on small
subsystems we don't characterize
individual operations stitch the
individual characterizations together to
predict the performance of the circuit
and this has been the dominant approach
in the community and unfortunately
there's a problem it does not work for
realistic area models it does not work
for a variety of reasons and then goes
through expand on it more but this is a
very important point
characterizing individual gates will
fail you need to do more than that and
I'll explain why throughout the talk so
how do people go about characterizing
the individual gates
well the canonical method is what the
most commonly used method these days is
to randomize benchmarking so suppose we
have a gate and the implementation of
the gate is going is a perfect
implementation followed by a static
arrow then if I apply a random sequence
of gates drawn from unitary to design
and then a correction gate that's just
the product of all the universes the
average over all gates is a nice
exponential decay you'll see these
exponential decays many many many
experimental papers
and this is a nice experiment because
the decay rate satisfies is directly
related to what's called the average
gate fidelity of the quantum process or
at the quantum gate which enables us to
provide a for provides a figure of Merit
for how well the gate is doing and this
is used routinely I'm just pretty sure
which was a showing something from the
paper I'm on to you do things like
assess in different implementations of
gates and say which one is better and
whether in particular operation you're
using is for particular pulse shaping
method you're using is working better or
not now the first problem with this is
unitary ours so there are three dominant
types of areas that we talked about this
stochastic areas
there's relaxation areas and these two
are fairly benign at least in them how
they relate to areas in a typical
circuit even though historically these
have been the dominant had the highest
probability they at least they're the
most predictable type of error and then
you have in that area areas and the
problem with the unitary errors is that
their effect depends very strongly on
the context I so what that means is it's
very difficult to decouple errors and
individual times in a circuit because if
there is complete focus much more or
they can he me a much faster and
randomized benchmarking gives the error
rate for a particularly benign input
measurement relation which is actually
the the most favorable one possible and
it may under estimate the actual error
by orders of magnitude so here is just
some quick simulations from a while ago
if I take the error rate is estimated
from randomized benchmarking input
dynast numbers of 10 to the minus 4
which is at the edges of what's
achievable and look at the total
variation distance for random 3 cubed
circuits the stochastic noise the output
from randomized benchmarking is
completely correlated with
the TVD in a random second however when
I look at the TBD the probability of an
error for a random circuit on the
unitary noise off the stick use the same
randomized benchmarking error rate I can
get orders of magnitude greater
probability of error so the first
solution here is to characterize the
unitary errors this is something you
definitely want to do you if you have an
area you can characterize and remove it
then you should so you can quantify the
unitary part of the error in it
basically by how well the process
preserves the purity of a state and that
gives a nice experiment for estimating
it you can basically do the same type of
randomized benchmarking experiment
except leaving off the recovery day
state recovery gate and you'll get an
exponential curve where the fidelity is
replaced by this unitarity and together
you can use the unitary and the fidelity
to accurately characterize the average
and West case errors for general noise
how air is accumulated in a circuit how
much control can be improved using
things like pulse distortions and so
it's quite a useful quantity but it
doesn't really hit at the bigger problem
that arises when you have more few bits
so for one or two qubits randomized
benchmarking in unit area great but you
could also just use process tomography
or something on those lines because the
dimension of the space is sufficiently
small but you don't really need
efficiency when you get to five ten
fifteen or hundred or thousand cubits so
millions of qubits in the future you
need to start worrying about emergent
phenomena in new era mechanisms and one
of the the big error mechanisms that's
emerged as relevant in the last couple
of years is crosstalk so crosstalk is
actually something that's relevant from
the classical telecommunications world
where turns transmitting a signal on one
channel creates an undesired effect on
another channel so here we just think of
the CP pulse as seen by the qubit
driving one
millennion you send a signal to
translate one Hamiltonian Hamiltonian in
your unintentionally activating another
the net effect of this is the gate that
you think should commute because the
abstract or operation does commute the
implement so while the abstract in
operations may commute the
implementations of those operations may
not generally will not which means you
have to worry about things like how do i
parallelized gates are they in series
how am i implementing you can have
solutions like canceling turns that's a
good thing to do however just you have
to compute the canceling turns or the
decoupling sequences for each
combination and less to come the
corresponding hamiltonians from you and
also if everything in your electronics
is linear so consequences the main one
is that the actual error model for
parallel parallelized gates is not well
defined mathematically and the error
model is also dominated by residual and
unitary errors because these if these
crosstalk signal so static then they
will put it more systematic they will
produce a coherent error and this is a
problem that we've known about for a few
years now it's been called
addressability and some devices from
length from ions with a shining lasers
on things and you're trying to focus the
beam onto a single ion it's also called
crosstalk when yes during a mainly by
control wires but running gates in
parallel gives notably worse error rates
than running gates in isolation so yes
some data from the what Thank You bit
IBM public device from last year and the
parallel numbers are essentially above
the parallel members for each qubit each
column is a qubit the orange is bigger
than the blue sometimes by an order of
magnitude in this case where I've got 2
times 2 minus 2 in parallel
compared to 2 times 10 to minus 3 in
isolation and the gaps are also not very
well correlated so that means a gate may
be really good in Ice in isolation and
much worse in power
what this means is that the notion of a
gate is computer science terms a leaky
abstraction you talk about a gauge in
your hope it encapsulates all the
relevant details but it doesn't it
misses too much important information
and that information is crucial to
determining how to do things like
compiling to a minimal depth or a
circuit with minimum error how to do
error correction at a mitigator is all
of these kinds of things need more
information than is encoded in gameplay
so when you have a bad abstraction you
should fix it the natural way to fix it
is to talk about a clock cycle and I'll
get to it a cycle in a CPU so here in a
clock cycle is based on a period of time
delta T and user-facing or theorist
facing which of me it corresponds to a
set of gates acting on subsets of
systems during the time period system
facing or towards the experimentalist it
really means what are the control
signals that will be applied during that
time period where that could include all
of the fancy decoupling sequences all of
the additional techniques but they spend
a lot of time trying to develop and
optimize and that means that if I have a
generic Soyka I can divide it up into
these time slices and each one is just a
clock cycle and what an important point
to notice is that everyone actually does
this already anyway so in many ways this
is not a new abstraction this is just
formalizing an old abstraction so that
means that cycles are actually extremely
practical for stationary noise where I'm
using a technical term to mean that it
doesn't have a systematic drift um then
we can describe a cycle by a linear map
and if we don't assume anything about
the dimension of the linear map then it
can include things like crosstalk or
coupling to an environment very easily
and then any well-defined measurable
objective function going to be used to
optimize the cycle such as the cross
entropy or the process fidelity so this
is being done ten years
sorry five years ago where the team at
Google quantum AI lab had started with a
cycle of operations on nine cubits and
they had a 40 percent error rate and
that was not particularly great but
those were the initial starting points
from the best best local carry best
independent characterizations so they
then used machine learning to try and
optimize it as a a credible cycle and
they got a reduction of a order of
magnitude in the error
so that means that you get to you can
optimize the cycle you can use it very
naturally to talk about error correction
but then it still leaves that problem of
pre-hearing areas thankfully we can get
rid of these using randomize compiling
where we take a circuit that's expressed
as a list of cycles and make an
artificial distinction between cycles
that are easy and hard where easy means
I can do it well with very little error
and hard means this is going to hurt and
this is going to have a very high error
rate and then what we do is around each
card cycle we put before the hand cycle
we insert virtual twirling cycles from
some set afterwards we insert the
correction and then here we have three
rounds of easy cycles and we don't want
to increase our overhead so we'll just
compile them into one so an example is
if I take the easy set to be arbitrary
single qubit gates on all qubits and the
hard set to be multi qubit clifford
gates and the twirling state is then
just multi qubit polygroup now this idea
is used as a variation of this idea is
actually used in error correction
literature quite extensively
particularly the surface code where
random operations are inserted here and
then the corrections are propagated to
the end so that works when everything is
a Clifford gate that Maps power least
families but if I'm using near-term
quantum computers or if I'm trying to
use compilation tools that have non
Clifford elements in them then as I
propagate this through the circuit it
will become eventually an arbitrary and
he'd be unitary operation which then
means I may as well have just simulated
the computer on the digital on a digital
device so you really have to do the
correction locally or before it's
propagate before it spread out too much
so Rena is compiling works experimental
it's been shown to reduce coherence and
also make the model
better fit to a model of non-markovian
of Markovian noise and it reduces areas
in typical circuits so this is data from
my VM Q again the 14th qubit Melbourne
device in taken in January
we're running random circuits and
looking at the probability of X so here
we have y axis is the probability of
error the x axis is the depth of the
circuit or in circuits without
randomized compiling we were circuits
with randomized compiling in orange as
high an important it's typical some
types substantially higher but in
important point is that even if it's
only just a little bit higher the orange
is only a little bit higher and you
don't see much reduction the other thing
is that you get a much more predictable
behavior from randomized component and
you do with without so just a very quick
brief because I don't like giving talks
in our proofs
let's take something where just a very
quick proof of randomized compiling so
it's we have three gate sets in
randomized compiling easy odd and the
twirling set and the criterion we want
is that the 12 instead when you
conjugate by an arbitrary hiset hot gate
has to go into an easy gate and that's
so that you can correct the errors
locally if this property is not
satisfied you will end up propagating to
you through generic entangling the
unitary and then suppose the noise is
sufficiently nice on the easy gates only
so we can write write it as a fixed
noise process followed by a
representation ideally you tend to you
bar followed by another fixed noise map
under those conditions randomize
compiling Maps a circle with
generic-looking noise where these meter
of page can be very noisy and a very
generic
processes into a much simpler one where
I've essentially gotten rid of most of
the most of the areas are reduced into a
single term that commutes with the
action
my representation and particularly with
the action of the representation of my
easy gait set so this is really crucial
because that typically means that I have
something that is diagonal and diagonal
noise ISM essentially much easier
they're related as though mentioned to
paddling channels so the brief is
actually pretty simple I mean a group
theory so if I take a term where I have
an easy Gator hard gate and an easy gait
what I'm doing in a randomized
randomized compiling I'm putting a
twirling gate here and then the
correction gate here and then I can
essentially use my assumption to rewrite
right these feeder terms for the easy
gates and the group homomorphism
property to take all the twelve gates
and put them in one spot and then when I
average over my twelve gates said I get
the desired result and I can do that
because nothing else in the circuit
depends on T whereas if I was
propagating everything would depend on T
and become like this so when my twirling
group contains the polygroup and there
is no environment shows lemma implies
the D is a stochastic power channel that
means I can write it as a probability
distribution over powering operators
which is really where with the kind of
primary motivation for enemy's compiling
it started out with I wanted to get rid
of two here in Eretz and part of the
reason for this is that stochastic power
channels are well-behaved they minimize
the error in a typical circuit in that
if I look over the space of all valid
quantum maps for a seat fixed cycle
fidelity the stochastic count only
channels are the ones that have the
smallest diamond norm and this protocol
is robust to arbitrary errors on hard
gates and you can prove perturbative
robustness to get dependent areas on the
easy gates which I generally have a much
smaller rate anyway now the reason is
sort of the
the next step to go there is with now
come come come from a gate level
abstraction realize okay we have
crosstalk that's a bad abstract so gates
a not a good abstraction we can turn
into cycles which are a much better
abstraction because they capture more
relevant details and then we can use
this randomize compiling to turn the
errors on those cycles into a much
simpler for now other questions can we
characterize those errors so the first
step in the gist direction from cycle
benchmarking so we can use randomized
compiling in some additional pre and
post-processing to estimate the error
per cycle acting on the entire quantum
computer and the total experimental cost
doing to estimate the Purser's fidelity
of an nqb process is completely
independent of the number of qubits and
practical so it's it's not just that the
constant is here extremely large but the
scaling is good it's actually both the
scaling is good and the constant is good
and the basic experiment is very similar
to a randomized benchmarking experiment
I'm going to run into leaf randomized
benchmarking experiment where I'm going
to do random gates and then I'm going to
put me in my cycle of interest random
gait cycle of interest random gait cycle
interest random gait with these random
gates have taken from my easy gate sense
the only difference is that I now need
to look at because I'm doing a weaker 12
I need to probe how my noise is
affecting different parts of the hilbert
space so I do that by selecting random
pounding operators and preparing
eigenstates of those operands so just to
demonstrate it was practical we looked
at the we implemented in experiment with
write a flat screw in a row on up to 10
cubits and the only reason it stopped at
10 is just because the numbers are
starting to get low and fitting in the
exponential to small to a fast decay is
very bad very hard so we didn't stop
because of the technique is just because
this is by the hardware time so here we
were looking at a looking and
characterizing tensor products of single
qubit operators and any way of looking
at the process fidelity of a awful tool
entangling MoMA Sorensen gate so this is
a global process acting on all n qubits
and the experimental run time four six
eight and ten cubits was exactly the
same up to some tiny fluctuations just
because there's a very slight changes in
parameters so how does this work how
does cycle benchmarking work well by
shows lemma each irreducible
representation will have a distinct in
my representation in from my noise map
is going to have a distinct decay rate
and in randomized benchmarking that
means have two different reducible
representations because I've got a
global clifford 12 so that means that
nothing is invariant except for the
identity operator in the other subspace
I can learn both of those in one
experimenter into an exponential decay
but it needs a global entangling gates
which are expensive to produce in
general in cycle benchmarking over a
much weaker 12 using local days and so
but I have more irreducible
representations for to the end of them
so that's an exponential number of
parameters that I could have I can learn
to to the end decay rates from one
experiment although these would not be
independent however I don't need to I
can sample an average and because the
decay rates end up because we proved it
okay rates are highly concentrated we
only need to sample a constant number of
these decay rates to estimate the
average to fix multiplicative precision
and the average is directly related to
the global process fidelity that
captures everything like cross talk
so that gives us a single number which
is good that single normal cap
characterize the process fidelity of a
length cubed process and we can estimate
it efficiently but if we want to do
something like error correction or error
mitigation it's not enough to know the
process fidelity we also need to know
what different errors to going on in our
cycle of interest because those are what
we need to correct or mitigate and
physically we expect areas to encourage
you to couplings and combinations of
small number of couplings and what that
means for the noise in room in
underground has been piling which can be
read in the house form there's a
probability distribution of how many
operators is that this probability
distribution of currently operators
should be sparse or have a tensile
network or it should be approximately
sparse but we don't expect in general
there to be a uniform distribution over
all curly errors as much as some
skeptics been used that as an error
model ease it's not what we see we see
different error rates in different
different probabilities of different
errors and they vary quite significantly
and some error rates some errors don't
happen very often at all now the decay
rates that we estimated cycle
benchmarking are actually the Walsh
Hadamard transform of the of this
probability distribution the nice thing
we can invert the transform and get the
decay rates the probabilities directly
however that on its own while powerful
is not very enabling because the
transform is ill conditioned and you
would have to learn all of them however
when you look at the inverse transform
you really you can see that it's
actually in a direct average and
rewriting in us the average allows you
to efficiently do the same thing of
sample the decay rates and average with
appropriate coefficients to learn the
probabilities using that basic idea
you can efficiently rink
striped marginal distributions so the
probability that an arrow will act on it
as an X on qubit one summed over all the
other things that can do on all the
other qubits and you can also look at
the probabilities of individual or
specific and qubit errors you can do
both of these reconstructions or
estimations efficiently in the number of
qubits
we can also stitch together the marginal
distributions into a globally consistent
distribution up to a normalization
factor so how does that work in practice
well we did some characterization on
IBM's public devices so they launched
five devices with five cubits in 2019 on
the same basic T architecture and the C
naught error rates as measured by
randomized benchmarking are 1% I just
want to emphasize if you read a paper
and someone says I have a C naught error
rate of 1% they mean that they have
estimated using randomized benchmarking
in its 1% this is the standard way
people estimate the error rates of the
gate it turns out that it is wrong that
it is the e standard way so if I have
four cycles so then we can look at these
t-shape and we go okay what cycles can
we produce from that well I can do four
cycles that have one Scene update
because there are four couplings and I
can do two seat cycles where I can
paralyze two couplings the naught 134
and one two three four and the single
cubed error rate to basically negligible
compared to the C naught error rates
again I was reported by randomized
benchmarking so then in January actually
while preparing the first version of
this talk I ran the data on some I and
my team ran some experiments some of it
while I was actually in the talk just
before so few nice to IBM for having
extremely reliable service that I could
do that but I can't we can
characterized all marginal distributions
on qubits targeted by one or two gates
so if cycles with one Scene up that
ended up being about 2,000 circuits and
this is somewhat comparable to three
cubed processed tomography and the
amount of information you get out and
about 6,000 circuits four cycles with
two c-notes which is again comparable to
four cubed process tomography and the
information it provides but no one has
actually done for qubit process
tomography fully now the number of
circuits per cycle actually scales
logarithmic ly with the number of
circuits and the sort of generation up
to a 30 40 cubits about too much
problems it's just getting that the time
to on the thing forty qubit devices is
somewhat elusive now we run this we get
a lot of data and an awful lot of data
and the main thing I'm going to point
out from this so the white the columns
are the different cycles the y-axis the
different power probabilities and I'm
not really going to point out to
anything except to notice that most
areas are correctly reported as
negligible and this is a very good thing
because this is exactly what we expect
we're not overfitting on this we're not
having to do any kind of joint
truncation anything on these lines
there's just naturally the method
without any kind of fancy
post-processing will say most errors
don't actually occur if most areas gonna
actually occur that being said it's very
hard to look at this table and get up a
very useful information directly so we
are going to remove all rows where all
areas avoid 30% of the maximum
probability and you get a lot less
popping out which is really quite nice
so just compare this one which has
several hundred rows to it to just be
ten or so dominant aromat arrow
mechanisms which we can identify
basically for free very very cheaply and
so what's important to note here is that
the single biggest errors on these
devices are actually the errors on idle
qubits and Zizi errors but the nzz
arizona idle qubits and the probability
that these errors occur is actually
worse than the error recorded by
randomized benchmark so enemies
benchmarking was reporting the total sum
of all errors on the C not as being
around 1%
whereas here we have a roughly of 5%
probability of a 0 on qubit 3 and
incidentally if we look realize the
accesses a little tricky to follow but
this column this row here is going is
the errors on the C naught itself on the
down the qubits that it's actually
targeting and the one which is purple
basically me is there's no real error
here and so the cycle that has the worst
error that was total error rate is
actually the one that has one of the
best see nots if you just look at the
qubits that are being affected by the
seen off so just to re-emphasize if you
take the randomized benchmarking numbers
and you say what's my best gate what has
the smallest error quantified just on
the systems that I'm actually acting on
that I think that I'm acting on you will
get the complete wrong order for what
operations are best compared to the
actual true errors I'm so Burlington and
other 5 cubed devices more extreme
completely dominated by single qubits
the air is not even as easy here
[Music]
so looking at that we thought okay can
we try and fix these sexy arrows so
randomized benchmarking can be used as a
metric top or a cost function dr. Mayes
gates there are some limitations in that
approach because it scrambles different
error types noise reconstruction we can
do is identify the dominant errors using
noise reconstruction then we can
construct a reduced set of experiments
to estimate those errors the
probabilities of those specific errors
and then we can sweep control parameters
that are tied to those errors even
virtually through a rumor API to someone
else's system to minimize those errors
and on IBM one I be employed in device
which I picked because it was the big
most dramatic of course we were able to
remotely reduce the Z errors from a
whopping forty percent so that what he
percent at the tiny gain Tassie not on a
pair a few bits on particularly on cube
is three and four as Z error would occur
on another pair on one of the idle
qubits and we could reduce that down to
10 percent there's a reason we couldn't
go lower in the amount of time we had
but basically what's happening just seen
showing the kind of suite parameter
we're looking at it as the compensation
angle that we're out officially
compiling in and the probability of the
error and you can see the yellow and the
blue with it oh sorry the orange and the
blue are the probabilities of extra
wires and they're not changing too much
as we change our Z compensation angle
which is exactly what we would expect
because but not really introducing as an
X or Y or we're introducing a zero then
the green changes so the zero point here
and one of the qubits as close to the
minimum a fairly clean but if I look at
one of the other qubits everything's a
little bit haywire at the default angle
that they have which is the setting that
they've calibrated is something like 80
degrees off the correct value when
you're doing a scene
and when you're that far off and you
have that eye and error probability a
lot of the fitting methods just start to
fail just as a so a minor point if you
see very christine arab are some things
that have fifty percent error
probability you should probably be
skeptical so why couldn't we get below
so in this case we could get to about
10% or 15% on qubit one sierra
well running noise reconstruction and on
the optimized version we find that we
have a large about a 10% probability of
as easy error we can't correct that
without using some more low-level access
low-level API tools that we have access
to and there's also a stochastic noise
floor where if I have eighty degree beam
offset on my Z I'm probably going to
have fluctuations about that when I for
fluctuations they end up being something
a contract systematically and notice
that the error in the scene not itself
is actually still negligible compared to
all of these other errors so it'd be
generally this the C naught that was
being run on qubits three and four was
perfectly fine it was doing an error
rate of something like one and a half
percent at the rest of the device on the
default setting had a 40% chance of
going haywire or even higher
ayman and with the optimized one it was
down to 10% that the scene on itself was
fine so he likes to kind of re emphasize
if you want to use a quantum computer
and you want to use it for something
especially where you can't check the
answer
you need to accurately and efficiently
model quantum computers and if you want
to try and improve the performance
you're going to need to do this
extremely well the standard approach
reporting errors in terms of individual
gates use the standard approach but it's
wrong it is inaccurate it does not count
traffic's like crosstalk and it probably
won't capture further immersion effects
as we go larger devices
morals based on cycles capturing more
experimental imperfections and are still
practical
and randomized compiling engineers a
more benign and predictable error source
that we can efficiently learn using
cycle benchmarking apparently noise
reconstruction just quickly we were
nicer just by the worker to that Derek
correction and medication techniques two
cycles with sparse noise and study trial
theory four cycles more and algorithm
compilation in terms of cycles and the
itches he would produce well the
features that were good were produced by
this team the pitches that were bad were
produced by me and these are great guys
to work with you produce the software on
a benchmark that I used and the theory
behind this was done in collaboration
with a lot of people and there are open
positions that you know Etsy Waterloo
end up on a bench plug sim please
contact me if you're interested thank
you very much well thanks so we can have
now some questions so I'm certainly
interested in asking a question I think
this is a very interesting study do you
think that if if you got the you know
Lex next level of access and you were
had your hands on this machine I presume
that you would know how to reduce these
error rates significantly I guess my
question is how far do you think you
could really go and do you think it'd be
even sort of another another layer of
errors that would remain beyond one's
reach or is there a feeling that one
could actually close this whole story
and really have genuinely a a quantum
processor that has low error rate in all
respects
so the single qubit gates that they have
are very good there on the level of 10
to the minus 4 yeah that is starting to
become you know it's not standard I
would say but it is the standard goal
and it is beaten in some places and some
platforms ok very occasionally with
gates that good we and knowing exactly
what the errors are we would know how to
insert so if you know you have as easy
coupling you know how to decouple you
know how to refocus that right you add
some X pulses on one of the qubits while
are you doing the cross resonance gate
and that will essentially refocus the is
easy I'm not sure exactly how well if
that would work but that is what they do
in labs anyway right the devices that
work well have these kinds of refocusing
pulses built-in
[Music]
I would say that those 10% 15% could be
completely eliminated as Dodman and
Aaron's mechanisms just by those
recovering pulses alone as to what the
residual noise mechanisms are will have
to run and say I Aine you I'm I don't
see any fundamental reason why we can't
have I know the devices exist that had
more than 20 cubits and I've it's much
smaller these are also IBM's power wave
devices so again they're not the best
iBM has to offer either so yeah we can
definitely get lower error rates the
exact amount I'm not sure mm-hmm
okay I can just jump in to citta there
some idea that's not for out there for
instance it free so that could lower
beyond echoing sequences as we just
mentioned I would have a question so I'm
very impressed that you can actually
improve the experiment so you know be
theorists are traditionally very good in
predicting the past yes walk me through
how long that takes and how much human
intervention is involved because you
know we learn from Google from the
really interesting part of the supremacy
paper which is technically appendix the
importance of efficient calibration so
can you walk me through the resources
that's that last demonstration needed
human and time yeah sure so this sweep
[Music]
so this sweep here to cook somewhat less
than 20 minutes remotely okay
and you took more data than I needed to
take okay
sorry fast but it was still
semi-automatic in the sense that you had
to do it well I had to stay here the
dominant Aries hmm
I mean it ended up being about five
you know I would say about four
lines the correct five lines okay in
like in my company software that's okay
like that it's not it's not yeah it's a
actually now is standard example in our
stuff I say if you go to our I don't
want to make it a sales pitch but if you
go to our documentation you'll see it as
an example yeah okay thank you so it's a
quick got a question to throw in how old
are these methods deal with drift or
continuous changes of parameterize a
short a long time sorry you're cutting
in and out yet but I she knows how well
does everything with rift the question
that it meaning that comes up is what's
the time scale if the time scale is
sufficiently long on the drift then
everything is fine when they if the time
scale is too fast I mean you're I say so
the 2000 circuits used for the five
cubits is slightly more than you need
because I was kind of going to beyond
what I would tend to recommend to be on
the default options but you would still
you know if you're not stable on the
order of a thousand circuits running
being able to run a thousand circuits
then we kind of help you I I don't think
anything you need to make a system more
stable but I mean and and what about I
mean because it's one thing to calibrate
the circuit and it's another thing to
have you know you calibrate the server
any parameters drift and then you have
to recalibrate have you done much work
into figuring out some optimal
calibration method or like you know some
optimal calibration repetition rates or
anything like that
that's a good question so I would say
that at least part of the problem with
calibration drifts is that they
introduce coherent areas those are all
that is suppressed so you can actually
go longer between calibrations I would
need to actually say how much of your
error rates drifting before I can even
really say you know you can write them
you would need to establish that your
error rates are stable within a certain
tolerance for a certain length of time
or have this much gradient and you can
start doing that with our techniques to
get kind of the base points but we
haven't had sufficient control over when
things are run to be out of times they
don't then do that study I will say that
I have not just just just a minor point
so these were ideas public devices right
they calibrate them once a day and I
actually took the data to do the sweep
and then did the reconsider is laid I
did the reconstruction with the data
point from the feeling so at least the
superconducting qubit platforms I know
of are capable of doing it and are
stable enough there's also a cycle but
data in the cycle benchmarking paper
with run a blast group showing where
they looked at the drift and it is
stable enough okay so we have a question
here from Dennis foolish says it's about
leakage or the question is have the
relation for the fidelity on slide 13
and the bounds on slide 14 being studied
for non trade preserving maps and says
that may be important in the presence of
leakage for instance
yes in fact I've seen that question from
that so the short answer is non tres
presiding
[Music]
you need an extra one and it's actually
a little bit complicated leakage is one
of those funny things it's funny because
it's in my experience it's an
experimentalist going to explanation for
anything that goes wrong it probably is
an explanation for some things that go
wrong but no one exposes an API where I
can actually study leakage no one
records to outcomes and so it's very
difficult for me to determine what's
going on and I have seen in a number of
cases where people said it was linkage
and it wasn't and the reason it was is
because they could try something else
that had nothing to do with leakage from
that fix the problem so leakage is
definitely a problem I don't know about
the exact nature of those bounds in a
sense because I'm not as concerned about
the exact nature of those balance those
times I was more concerned with because
I realized that there is a problem the
gap between them is massive and that gap
will obviously be just as big or bigger
if I have leakage and so the question
for me was how do I get rid of the gap
to make things more predictable and I do
that using randomize compiling which
will work in the presence of leakage the
same the basic math works
I still get something where I
diagonalize it the channel and it
doesn't really matter whether it has
linkage or not so I sort of know and but
at the same time I don't think it's the
most pressing question maybe I could
intervene and bring us to a halt so that
we could have a five minute break say
but I thank you and I think that was a
very interesting con contribution so
let's take a five-minute break
some people can have coffee some people
can have lunch dr. Holm can take out the
trash I will thank you